it's just the most extraordinary story
this shown and we still don't know the
full extent of the damage but certainly
it has definitely caused a lot of
embarrassment to the US so far let's
just look in more detail if we can what
these documents look like and what
potentially some of them reveal one of
the things that's been perplexing most
military analysts is how we're 21 year
old with a security clearance but
relatively simple managed to get hold of
some top secret documents then print
them out and whether it's not just like
printing off here or back at home there
are very complicated procedures for
printing off any secret documents now
that we've actually got photographs of
the documents itself now we can actually
start to talk to us a bit more a picture
we've got here which is a lot of the
information has been blurred out quite
deliberately because actually some of
it's still confidential right and
although these are of two months old
we've left a map on because we use maps
regularly in um if a broadcasting terms
but I'll draw your attention right to
the top it talks about Russia Ukrainian
joint staff spring brief now what this
is is that the very senior levels of the
US military the senior generals will get
a daily brief from all of the Ops
intelligence Logistics folks for all the
key operational areas in the world so
Ukraine potentially any areas like China
North Korea and stuff like that this is
one of the briefings that they will have
been given on a daily basis sometimes
several times a day now normally those
briefings are given in a digital format
in other words like a PowerPoint
presentation but most senior officers
like to be able to make notes as well so
they give them a little pack of hard
copy which they can make notes which of
course should be collected at the end of
the event now hold on to that thought
for a moment very difficult for a 21
year old to get hold of the electronic
version and even if you did why wouldn't
he not share electronic version with his
mates online far easier if he had access
to that briefing room after those
seniors are left some of the seniors
have taken out some of the pages they're
written notes on and he was able to pick
up scraps from that briefing room he'd
fold them up you can see how the folds
on this that he would then pop in his
jacket pocket and that would explain why
there's a load of different unconnected
documents that go back several months in
an apparently random fashion and
therefore this is probably less about
him securing it digitally more about him
harvesting paper copies and sharing them
with his colleagues now of course it's
been a huge breach of national security
for the for the US its allies and
crucially Ukraine which is in a live War
situation uh details of of this amount
of air defense systems it has left
highly highly sensitive stuff that could
could really harm them operationally
what have we learned and what does it
mean when I first saw some of the
details I was mortified because it's
about the vulnerabilities of the
ukrainians it's how well prepared they
were for their operations but
intelligence is very time sensitive and
therefore a lot of this information was
back from January in the year and as you
as you've quite rightly said let's use
an example of the air defense systems at
Kiev they were so crucial right now
and what are we going to do about it but
actually if you look back part of those
documents one of the reasons those
documents are generated to go to the
International Community to get them to
donate more missiles so that's not a
problem anymore what you're looking at
is a part of the process from weeks
maybe months ago that highlights a
problem and therefore that alerts the
communities to correct it and that's one
of the reasons why the U.S concerns
there are lots of U.S concerns about
Ukrainian counter-offensive and lots of
other things but if you look back all of
all of those to my knowledge have now
been resolved so there's actually what's
the face value it's worrying in reality
it's not that concerning and of course
there's also been leaks that are
potentially concerning for the ministry
of Defense here as well revealing that
UK special forces are working in Ukraine
what more can you tell us about this
first of all the UK never comments on
whether the Special Forces where they're
operating when they're operating why
they're operating they are an elite
military capability for our nation they
usually go in for a specific thing they
go and they come out again the mod
interestingly did not verify or cancel
or say no this wasn't true or was true
what they said was a serious level of
inaccuracy about the reports almost
certainly whatever was happening on the
1st of March when when
their first March when this issue came
out almost certainly those situations do
not exist today so I don't know whether
SF were there or not but almost
certainly the information out there is
no longer valid no longer credible